Ya, me sigue votando los comento.
Ya, voy a intentar.
Esperamos que no se ponga.
Ya en el PX ya saben, en el HN listo, abritamos.
Esperamos un gacho.
Ya, mientras tanto voy a grabar la clase, a ver, a grabándose que no hirvió de un
cachito.
No sé qué tiene, pero algo está pasando con mi sistema.
Ya está bien lento.
Mientras va, en este caso compilando, vamos a proceder a hacer lo siguiente.
Y los voy a pasar también lo siguiente.
Pena abriendo Word.
Para capturarme las pantalitas siguientes.
Ya lo mismo, ya, van a capturar y todo lo que han hecho entre las clases y lo voy a
aplicar acá.
Ya, esta parte, lo mismo, ya, voy a enserrándolo y voy a abriendo Word.
Si es que pueden, por ser caso, los que acaban de entrar, les acabo de decir que por Cristianos
de que la anterior clase no le podía subir la grabación, porque mi volta se cae y en
ese aspecto, es lo que voy a subir esta noche.
Así que la tarea de hoy pueden entrar a la dala hasta la siguiente semana, en el ligo,
hasta el jueves, así, para que puedan adjuntar.
Ya no hay problema en ese aspecto.
Así que aquí lo mismo, ya, clase número 5 sería esta parte.
Vamos a quedar en clase número 5.
Y dentro de ahí van a colocar, en este caso, implementación de Google App.
Ya, es caso Gmail, automatizaciones, con IA.
Listo.
Paso 1, vamos a colocar implementación.
De procesos.
Ya.
Ahora sí, ya, listo.
Una vez que hayan, en este caso, compilado su proyecto, voy a apretar al tecla O y directamente
vamos a ingresar ya.
Así que esperamos un cacho.
Si no les quiero habilitar, voy a copiar esto.
Se me ha empujado hasta el menú.
Y voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Ya.
Esperaremos.
Listo.
Ya.
Ahora, antes de empezar, la anterior clase habíamos quedado en esto.
Habíamos hecho lo que es un Google Sheet con lo que me van a enviar.
No, ya voy a repartir algunas cositas y luego voy a hacer de nuevo desde cero, pero otro aspecto.
Ya, y al último, ustedes ya lo pueden incorporar, encripular y lo demás.
Ya, así que, empezar en los.
Mi chévere está fuera.
Espero que no lo detecte la grabación.
Ya, hacemos doble clic acá y voy a hacer lo siguiente.
A ver, lo siguiente, chicos.
Habíamos hecho también lo otro parte, ¿no?
Que en este caso voy a abrir mi otra cuenta de Google, donde había creado mi Google Sheet.
Ya, en este caso, dentro de mi cuenta, era esta, era acá.
Y aquí voy a irme directamente a la parte de Google Sheet.
Ya, voy a irme a Google Sheet.
Listo.
Ya, hojas de cálculo o Google Sheets.
Y en base a eso voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Aquí les hemos quedado el Excel, ¿no?
Hacemos clic.
Ya, esto.
Ahora, digamos que yo quiero aumentar más fases.
Es decir, ya hemos agregado anterior fecha y hora.
Ahora voy a agregar en este caso, no sé.
Lugar, digamos.
¿Qué podemos colocar? Nombre completo, teléfono, email, departamento, país.
Fecha y hora y voy a colocar...
Ya.
Sédula de Antigalta.
Ya, sédula.
Una vez que he añadido ahí directamente, voy a irme acá.
¿Cómo voy a irme acá?
Dentro de mi...
Volvamos a repetir acá.
Dentro de lo que es App and Row in Sheet, voy a hacer clic, doble clic.
Y me va a aparecer esta interfaz.
Ya.
Ahora, si nos damos cuenta, cuando yo añado en este caso, acá, una nueva columna.
Aquí si nos damos cuenta, me va a aparecer una actualización.
Refresh. Hago refresh.
Y miren, se aumenta una variable.
Y esta variable, yo tengo que trabajar en base a eso.
Ahora aquí, por ejemplo, aquí me está diciendo qué variables yo voy a implementarlo.
Ya.
Vamos a ver acá.
Si halve esto, miren, puedo jalarlo ahí.
También puedo jalar Form out.
Ya.
Pero en este caso, yo voy a colocar Ejecutar Step.
Al ejecutar esto,
debería de aparecer todo lo siguiente.
Bien, voy a colocar en este caso,
Minton, voy a colocar 32,
se lo chichenó, no lo sé, me estoy inventando un teléfono, un Gmail.
Minton, lo sé.
Minton, alt 64, Gmail, Ponto com.
Y Departamento País, voy a crear Bolivia.
Visto, voy a añadirlo.
Ya.
Y aquí se debería de actualizar mientras tanto.
Ya es actualizado.
Ya.
Entonces,
cuando nosotros trabajamos con ese tipo de aspectos,
podemos ver aquí y aumentar más variables,
pero voy a enseñar ahorita cómo vamos a manejar algunos puntos más.
Ya, antes de hacer eso,
de esta parte igual,
le completo, lo voy a borrar esta parte para que tengan idea que estoy haciendo acá.
Ya.
Hasta aquí habíamos hecho todo normal, ya.
Ahora fíjense,
dentro de mi columna de lo que era mi Google,
estoy colocando esto,
le ha aumentado una columna donde dice fecha y hora de registro.
O sea, ustedes van a aumentar así.
Voy a borrar esto, y chau esto,
y esto chau.
Voy a colocar fecha,
fecha y hora.
Ya, de freja.
Nada más.
Ahora esta parte,
este submitted me dice eso.
Ahora, si actualizo de nuevo,
me debería aparecer esto.
Fecha y hora de inicio.
Ya.
Voy a dejar esto.
Jalo.
Y me va a adjuntar directamente lo que es un JSON submitted.
Ahora esta parte, chicos,
es JavaScript.
Ya.
Fíjense ahorita el formato, el formato de sal.
Dice 2026, 05, 16,
de no sé qué y tanto.
O sea, hasta desde este puntito está medio que no entendible para un usuario.
O sea, no sé qué es,
pero hasta aquí le entiendo,
porque sé que es 16 de mayo del 2026.
Entonces para ello pueden agregar algo de formato.
Pueden colocar punto,
y aquí les va a aparecer to the time
que me dé el tiempo.
Hago click.
Y fíjense,
se va modificando algunas cositas acá.
Si coloco de nuevo punto,
me dice qué tipo de formato quieres utilizar.
Vea con qué formato.
Click.
Y fíjense, ya me da
año, mes,
y día.
Pero yo quiero juntar otras cosas más.
Por ejemplo, ahora,
voy a colocar hh.
Listo.
Dos puntos.
Voy a colocar
or,
minuto,
mm.
Dos puntos.
Voy a colocar ss de segundo.
Listo.
Una vez que ejecuto eso,
le coloco ahí,
y hasta automáticamente.
Ahora sí puedo ejecutarlo.
Ya.
Y cuando ejecuto,
fíjense acá.
Ya se añade.
Ahora voy a trabajar de la siguiente manera.
Miren lo siguiente que voy a hacer.
Voy a cerrar esto.
Ahora acá arriba dice publicar.
Van a hacer click ustedes en publicar.
Van a colocar publish.
Ya.
Hasta ahí lleguen.
Tiene que estar publicado esta cosa.
Publicando eso ahorita.
Esperemos un poco.
Y se va a publicar automáticamente.
Ya.
Aquí también pueden colocar otras variantes.
No hay problema.
Ahora, una vez que lo publican,
para saber si está publicado o no,
puede mirar esa página principal que dice N8N.
Y si se dan cuenta aquí está una franjita verde.
Ya.
Voy a volver a entrar.
Como ya está publicado,
voy a volver a entrar acá.
Al append.
Verifico que todo esté bien.
Total cual.
Lo voy a volver a cerrar.
Ahora voy a irme acá.
Voy a decir ejecutar workflow.
Como ya está publicado.
Voy a hacer esto.
Click.
Ahora voy a añadir un dato diferente.
Voy a añadir un external.
El Hamilton.
Voy a añadir otro nombre.
Voy a utilizar Mauricio.
Hasta me estoy inventando.
Mauricio.
Alroba.
J1000.
Partamentos Santa Cruz.
Listo.
Lo subimos.
Y automáticamente acá debería de automáticamente juntarse.
Ya.
Ahora.
Lo siguiente.
Voy a cerrar esto.
Les voy a pasar a ustedes.
Para pasarles a ustedes esta partecita,
igual pueden estar sacando sus screens de pantalla
para que no se vayan desubicando esa parte.
Vamos a abrir ahora nuestro en Rock.
Ya.
En este caso voy a abrir una nueva CMD.
Ahora ya has hecho como se abre en Rock.
Voy a repetírselos.
Voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Voy a abrir una carpeta.
Una carpeta.
Voy a mostrar la carpetita.
Esta carpetita voy a irme donde le guardo mis...
Extensiones.
En este caso creo que le he guardado en drivers.
Y le he puesto...
No, no le he guardado en drivers.
Le he guardado en...
A ver, un cachito.
Ah, mis templos.
Ya.
En Hnr, voy a colocarlo acá.
Y aquí está.
Y el instalador les dice.
En Rock.
Ya.
Les ha hecho que tienen que copiarse esto.
Luego lo voy a minimizar.
Y aquí voy a colocar CD.
Pego.
Y me voy a entrar ahí.
Ahora.
Para compilar esto.
Les había dicho que tienen que cocar en Rock.
Config.
En este caso.
ADD.
Guion.
Out token.
Listo.
Y en este caso.
Tienen que colocar lo que es el código.
Ya.
Que ya los he hecho que se tienen que grabar.
En mi caso lo voy ahorita a buscar.
Aquí está.
Listo.
Aquí lo pego y listo.
Dice accesión de negado.
¿Por qué?
Porque en este caso les había comentado que...
De un cachitibox.
A ver, a ver, a ver.
Ya sé por qué me estaban cortando el mito.
Ya.
Me estaban bañando así que.
Va a ver que ya se ha quedado.
De un cachitibox.
Ya.
Ahora sí.
De un cachitichico.
Voy a defender esto.
Ya.
Una vez que tienen eso entonces.
Voy a deshabilitar.
Aunque por 10 minutos.
Mi.
Mis escudos.
Lo desactivo.
Por qué el que te desactiva.
Y normales.
Venga esa.
Ahora vuelven a probar.
Ya.
Y normales va a ingresar.
Ahora vuelven a probar.
Y deberías decir auto-save.
Ya.
Listo.
Hasta ahí lo tienen.
La mayoría.
Ahora para hacer correr esto.
Les había hecho que tienen que colocar en rock.
HTTP.
5678.
Listo.
Ahora les tomaré lista de acá.
Ya.
Voy a irme acá.
Hago clic.
Esto me voy a copiar.
Siempre haránse un blog de notas muy aparte.
Me voy a abrir blog de notas.
Ya.
Y voy a abrir unito nuevo.
Por ejemplo acá.
Aquí lo estoy mostrando.
Este es para mi.
Mi.
Lo que me está dando el túnel de en rock.
Ya.
Voy a seguir acá.
En one force emission.
Ahora lo voy a colocar en modo producción.
Me voy a copiar todo esto.
Y lo voy a volver a pegar acá.
Ya.
Ahora qué es lo que voy a hacer yo?
Netamente.
Esto voy a copiarme.
Y lo voy a copiar acá.
En vez de.
Hasta acá.
Todo esto lo voy a eliminar.
Y lo voy a pegar ahí.
Listo.
Todo esto ahora.
Los voy a pasar a ustedes.
Pero yo me voy a abrir desde otro lado.
Voy a abrir desde una interfaz alterna.
Que tengo.
Listo.
Voy a venirme acá.
Ya.
Y lo voy a hacer.
Por ejemplo, esto no.
Voy a visitar el sitio.
Y en este caso voy a colocar el nombre.
Digamos.
Voy a llamar María o Juana.
Listo.
Juana.
Arroba.
Químico.com.
Aquí voy a colocar.
Colombia.
Listo.
Subimos.
Y listo.
Voy a ver ahora mi.
Formulóvia.
Ya está.
Juan.
Se ha admitido.
Ya.
A partir de acá voy a llamar.
Yo.
Lista.
En la.
Formular de mit.
Ya.
Vayan.
Ingresando.
Y vayan.
E.
Colocando las asistencias.
Ya.
Listo.
Yo voy a colocar cada otro color.
Si tú estoy los que ingresen.
Pues ya van a ser.
Diferentes.
Ya.
Ahora sí.
Vayan.
Anotando sus nombres en la lista.
Y normal.
Listo.
Vayan.
Y no.
Yo.
Voy a actualizar.
Debería actualizar automaticamente esto.
Ya está.
Javier.
Andrés.
Vidal.
Ya está uno.
Ángel.
Eugenio.
Charca.
Listo.
Otro.
Exacto.
Bien.
Hasta ahora somos 4.
Ahorita somos en clase 19.
Debe bien estar 17 mínimo.
Bueno, lo voy a admitir a alguien más.
Ya está.
Patricio.
Ya.
Y aquí también van a tener en cuenta lo siguiente.
Van a ver que en algunas de sus pruebas.
Si van a ver aquí Mónica, digamos.
De nada vas a empezar con otro nombre.
Porque generalmente.
Esto en 8 en 10.
Y en el 8 en 10.
Esto en 8 en 10 trabaja mediante una velocidad.
Y esa velocidad que trabaja.
Ahí veces es muy lente.
Muchos dependen de la computadora que están utilizando.
Pero hay que tomar en cuenta algunos aspectos ahí.
¿Cómo pueden saber eso?
Mientras van ingresando ahí.
Voy a venir acá.
¿Viste lo que voy a cerrar?
Voy a venir a mi en 8 en 10.
¿Cómo pueden saber eso?
Viven acá.
Lo van a cerrar esto.
Vean, vean, se ejecución es.
Y ahí pueden ver.
¿Quién está notando ahorita?
Y fíjense.
La latencia.
Viren acá.
2.2 segundos.
1.918.
Fíjense.
19.04, 28, 19.03.
No hay mucha ahorita.
Aquí pueden chocar.
Miren.
Estos dos datos están.
Pueden que choque.
Porque hay una velocidad muy pequeña de latencia.
Y si van a ingresar más personas.
Por ejemplo, 1.000 personas, 800 personas.
Y quieren ingresar al mismo tiempo.
Pueden tener estos problemas.
Se puede mejorar.
Sí.
Eso vamos a avanzar en una clase posterior.
Cuando hay que mejorar las latencias de respuesta.
Esto para qué?
Para que no sobre poner a un usuario encima de otro usuario.
Ya.
Eso hay que tener mucho en cuenta cuando ejecutamos estas cositas.
Ahora sí.
Voy a irme a mí.
¿Listo?
¿Y hasta cuántos?
1, 2, 3, 6, 5, 6.
¿Y si se le falta?
¿En todavía altos?
Ya pues, ya se te va a hacer su lista de hoy día.
Así que, traten de llenarlo ahorita mismo.
Si pueden para no tener problemas.
Ya.
Ahí está.
Que se vean actualizando los demás.
Ya.
Pasaremos ahora a otro tema, chicos.
Ya lo pueden enlazar luego más cosas y más cosas.
Pero ahora voy a avanzar a otra cosita más.
Vamos a ir en avance directo.
Ya.
Vámonos a nuestro NCHON.
Ahora vamos a crear un nuevo workflow.
Ya.
Crearemos uno nuevo.
Y antes de hacer esto, voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Ya.
Una vez que hayan creado uno nuevo, ya podemos empezar a trabajar en base a Gmail.
Y en estos Gmail voy a tratar de trabajar con 1.4.1.
Y vamos a trabajar con lo siguiente.
Ya.
Puedo un cachito.
Venimos acá y vamos a elegir acá 1.4.1.
Hagan clic.
Bueno, en este caso es un formulario en la cual yo voy a registrar o voy a capturar datos de mi cliente.
O voy a capturar datos de cualquier tipo de personas que esté interactuando con mi sistema.
Ya.
Así que en este caso acá voy a colocar un formulario.
Voy a colocar.
Ya.
Voy a colocar empresas.
Empresas.
Industriar.
Ya.
No sé.
Pocas.
Cosa.
En vez de coca-cola coca-cosa vamos a ver.
Para que no me llegan algo.
Aquí fue una descripción.
Voy a colocar.
No voy a colocar nada.
Aquí empezaremos a leer algunos elementos.
Ya.
El primer elemento que voy a añadir necesariamente va a ser el nombre completo.
O sea, qué quiero capturar de mi cliente.
Qué quiero capturar en base a sus datos personales.
Ya.
Nombre completo.
Voy a colocar en este caso tipo texto está bien.
No hay el lío.
Atributos como quiero que sea un valor requerido obligatoriamente.
Voy a añadir otro.
Vamos a añadir en este caso cédula.
Esa es la mente de nacito o número de cédula.
Cédula.
Ya.
Y aquí voy a colocar igual tipo námbar.
Y aquí voy a añadir requerimientos obligatorio.
Voy a añadir uno más.
Qué más necesito su email.
Necesito su email.
El email en este caso.
Voy a colocar el tipo email.
Y en este caso voy a colocar requerido también.
Es un argumento requerido.
Y por último puedo añadir en este caso.
Que se llama.
Condición.
Petición puedo colocar.
Observaciones y no.
Usa requerimientos.
Listo.
Dentro de acá voy a colocar abajo dice text area.
Donde el cliente va a poder requerir.
No sé.
Cómo es una empresa de Coca-Cola.
Coca-cosa.
Estamos diciendo que puede.
No sé.
Un cliente va a poder decir.
Quiero.
No sé.
Con la cola de un litro.
Dos paquetes de Coca-Cola de tres litros.
Y etcétera.
Y al.
Es que me diga y requerimiento obligatorio.
Añadimos eso.
Y listo.
Ya.
Y acá abajo en opción van a colocar.
Apen.
En el 8 en atribución.
Y en ahí van a.
Describir esto.
Ya.
Hasta ahí.
Hasta ahí más o menos los voy a esperar.
Para que lo tengan.
Ya pueden ejecutar.
Ya ejecutan lo.
Y lo tendría que salir esto.
En base a sus criterios.
No quiero que copien lo mismo.
Si no, es que lo que hagan una.
Un ejemplo similar.
Ya.
Lo bueno del text area.
Que esto se puede extender.
Y ahí pueden colocar un montón de.
Argumentos más.
Ya.
No hay río.
Ahora lo que yo necesito es lo siguiente.
Voy a colocar un stop.
Voy a solar esta parte.
Y ahora voy a acomodarme algunas cosas.
Ya.
Voy a irme directamente acá.
Y voy a colocar edit.
Ya.
Dentro de edit.
Van a colocar edit.
Ya.
Eso van a clicarlo.
Y van a cerrar esto.
Ya está.
Hasta ahí mientras tanto necesito que vayan haciendo.
Y esto lo van a unir.
Acá.
Listo.
Hasta el chico.
Cos.
Podemos capturar un dato de prueba.
Para ver si realmente está funcionando.
Así que venían acá.
Vamos a colocar un ejemplo de prueba.
Voy a colocar Juan.
Juan Pérez.
Número solo.
Listo.
Juan.
Aquí por si acaso.
Cuando trabajemos con este tipo de proyectos.
Si es necesario que coloquen quizás una.
Image verdadero.
Ya.
En este caso voy a colocar.
Voy a colocar mi usuario mejor.
Listo.
Voy a colocar acá mi nombre verdadero en todos.
Y aquí voy a colocar.
O sea quiero.
Para.
La.
Sona.
Norte.
Tiene.
Una.
Tienda.
Número.
No sé.
45.
Una cantidad.
De dos paquetes.
De.
Coca cola.
De dos litros.
Luego otro necesito.
Vaya puedo extender esto si quede segno y acomodarlo de mejor manera.
Voy a colocar.
Si.
Una Coca cola de dos paquetes de Coca cola.
Luego.
Un paquete.
De salvieti.
De dos litros.
Listo.
Esta traceta.
Ya.
Listo.
Colocamos acá.
Ya se genera eso.
Pero lo fíjense si voy a bajar esto un cachó.
Este ya debería estar desarcionando.
¿Qué hace el edit fills?
El edit fills.
Netamente hace una captura de datos.
Netamente captura.
Ya.
Ahora lo bueno del edit fills.
Aparte de capturar.
Me genera algún tipo de procesamiento de datos.
Cuando luego lo vamos a checar más o menos cómo se va a manejar ese aspecto.
Pero me genera ese tipo de la noticción.
Ya.
Ahora voy a empezar a trabajar de la siguiente manera.
Aquí van a hacer doble clic.
Y aquí le van a colocar.
Y aquí le van a poner.
Aquí, verán, se clica y se guila.
Van a colocar formulario de contacto.
¿Listo?
Para que se actualice.
Y entendamos en español más que todo cómo está manejándose.
De aquí vamos a colocar procesamiento de datos.
¿Listo?
Los cierro.
así tiene que aparecer esto lo van a capturar y lo van a llevar a su
huerto hasta acá ya así que captura uno vamos a colocarlo
captura uno
y ya listo vamos al siguiente punto aquí van a colocar solamente en adelante captura
y esto se pueden copiar más para no estar haciendo lo más veces
y está y ya está ahora si volamos acá estoy volando me van a decir chicos para darles tiempo
una vez que llegamos acá ya tengo datos capturados voy a hacer clic acá
en procesamiento de datos se dan cuenta ya tengo una entrada de datos y los había hecho en un
principio de las clases no ver estos son los inputs todo lo que entra y esto no es output solo
que sale ahorita lógico estoy ingresando de aquí datos y esto me está llevando hasta acá y
esto están ingresando pero todavía no tengo la salida no tengo todavía la salida que van a
hacer acá lo que van a hacer en este caso es netamente jalar cada uno de estos bloques
fíjense jalan los suelten acá listo ahora el otro también lo jalan y los suelten acá
y los demás también el email y el recrimiento listo hasta ahí luego puedo colocar submit
para las fechas pero mientras tanto estoy manejando esos parámetros ya ahora lo voy a ejecutar
aquí también pueden colocar y no hay conversa pero todavía no vamos a avanzar
ahí mejor lo mantendremos ejecutamos y debería de parecer es acá todos sus datos
ven entonces hasta ahí quiero que me hagan la siguiente captura
listo voy a colocar lo captura número 2
van a colocar aquí su nombre por si acaso acá donde dice nombre completo vayan jugando con
sus nombres y correos verdaderos troten de trabajar porque ahorita vamos a enlace
con coros verdaderos ya y ahora eso es lo mismo chicos ven acá captura número 2 y van a añadir
listo voy a minimizar voy a proceder a lo siguiente una vez que ejecutan eso ahora vamos a enviar
un coro personalizado ya van a cerrar esto
que les espera un poquito que nos vea dar unos 2 minutos más y mientras van
restando esa parte ya van a volar rápido
y vayan hoy en haciendo esto y chicos
ya una vez que lo tienen hasta ahí voy a empezar acá hago clic de nueva que
no es panel voy a escribir y me
hacen clic en gmail y se vamos a buscar cuál nos conviene ya
añadir un mensaje eliminar un mensaje dar un mensaje que te mere mis agentes margen
mensaje y vamos a colocar sent a mesas o sea quiero mandar un mensaje click
y acá fíjense también es lógico no porque porque mi input está en esa cadenita que ha
pasado hacia acá ahora esto está pasando acá esto está todavía tiene que admitir así que
en ese aspecto ya puedo colocar acá listo ahora qué hacemos acá generalmente aquí me dicen
que no van a cambiar tengo que enviarlo obviamente la operación de enviar aquí también pueden
cambiarlo si que desean ya no es necesario hacerlo de un principio cuando hemos buscado ver el
get un mensaje aquí también pueden hacerlo directamente pero voy a dejarlo como sent porque
estamos enviando un mensaje ahora acá van a colocar un correo que sea verdadero para ustedes
ya en este caso voy a colocar voy a abrir una cuenta nueva tengo un correo utilizo
así que voy a ver acá
y aquí hasta el color a la metid listo si tengo flojera digamos voy a hacer acá
listo aquí voy a colocar entonces
hago clic esto y lo pego acá
listo ahora quiero en este caso qué cosa quiero decirle digamos al usuario que en este caso
tengo que enviar ya por ejemplo o la mundo puedo enviarlo o posible no sé pedidos pedidos
listo ahora fíjense acá el tipo de email que yo la voy a enviar puede podemos trabajar de
diferentes maneras fíjense acá puede enviar lo tipo texto o puedo enviar lo tipo html esto es más
que todo para los desarrolladores para los reguajos voy a enseñar ahorita cómo lo van a colocar
mientras tanto vamos a enviar lo tipo texto ya y voy a colocar aquí el mensaje ahora si quieren
colocar un mensaje bien extenso pueden hacer lo siguiente por ejemplo deseo
podemos colocar acá si no es un mensaje que que se desespuesta en base este email por si acaso ya
en su pedido será enviado el día de mañana
a horas
8 a m. ya que puedo jalar algunas cosas para volver miran acá si hago clic acá me parece esto
y aquí a puedo editar más cositas o se puede hacer lo bonito extenso y demás no hay problema
y ahora puedo también jalar esto miren nombre completo su pedido señor Milton blanco
será adjuntado para esa fecha de los su pedido será enviado su pedido hasta lo voy a cortar
su pedido Milton tanto tanto lo coloco será enviado y aquí y aquí aparece miren su pedido
Milton blanco será enviado y ya puede colocar si no señor
Milton blanco será enviado el día de mañana a las horas 18 8 a m. nada más pueden colocar así
ustedes tienen que dar algún tipo de formato ya ahora no lo voy a extender más cosas porque
aquí dice que tengo que tener una credencial porque a mí no me va a dejar ejecutar si no tengo una
credencial de la pide google así que yo ya tengo un montón de credenciales acá pero voy a crear
con ustedes una nueva ya para crear eso voy a habilitar donde estaba mi correo aquí voy a
echarme a google clout y en google club voy a entrar acá y en este caso voy a irme a consola o a
consola hasta ahí les espero no estoy chico los espero para que no volar mucho muy rápido
y no se nos está ahí hay no importa que el mensaje que usted envía es a través de la cuenta de
gravity y la google club es por Milton porque en este caso mi centralizador va a ser el que estoy
creando ahorita no decir mis centralizadores este porque aquí está mis cuentas o sea este ahorita
que voy a crear ahorita mi api es el que vas a excepcionar es como un puente como me están
enviando a ese ese sistema al correo interno que estoy creando ahí va a llegar los mensajes y de
me van a reenviar a mis demás clientes ahorita esto esta parte del input no lo tome muy en serio
porque esta parte estábamos nosotros haciendo pruebas esto es lo que me interesa ahorita esto
y la cuenta principal ahorita le van a entender cómo es el flujo y ahí se van a dar cuenta cómo se
trabajan pero mientras tanto solamente me interesa este y solamente me interesa la p
donde voy a crear eso eso mantenga los yosí de manera real este se pueden inventar pero ahorita
lo vamos a demandar de manera verdadera con otros cuentas eso sigue si trabajen de manera correcta
y en aquí si tienes razón porque aquí debería de colocar mi cuenta normal pero ahorita lo vamos
a modificar eso ahorita quiero principalmente en activar lo que es la api y en base eso vamos a
jugar ya así que vienen acá voy a aumentar ya saben esto directamente aquí voy a buscar
netamente lo que es y mail ya para hacer eso voy a irme a lo que es acá voy a irme a api
servicios y voy a irme a biblioteca ya esa partecita acu acuérdense api servicios biblioteca
y en ahí voy a buscar gmail api y a gmail api dentro de este gmail api les va a aparecer a ver
apretender enter y que vaya buscando aquí ya tengo gmail api ya hacen click
pero ojo antes de activar los dientes ya está activado porque he estado yo trabajo en ese
sistema pero aquí está esto fíjense que están trabajando en su n8 que han creado anterior clase
por si caso para no estar volviendo a crear de nuevo todo ya ahí lo activan erigen primero esto
y lo van a activar acá ya una vez que lo activen ya está eso es todo ahora por
ahí quizás sones se han olvidado sus credenciales ya porque aquí solamente estoy habilitando la api
no estoy creando una credencial es para eso volvemos atrás o vemos acá voy voy a irme directamente
api servicios y voy a irme a credenciales entra a credenciales digamos que yo me olvidado mi
usuario no sé ni porque la se hecho en anterior clase tienen que guardar su ad y tienen que guardarse
su clave su contraseña ya ahora si es que no sé de yo no tengo acá por ejemplo gmail api
por ejemplo ahí si es que se han olvidado y no lo han guardado pueden entrar acá a client web
uno ese client les va a decir lo siguiente miren acá van a ver lo siguiente aquí si
se dan cuenta llame de la id ahora porque quiero la id porque si nos vamos de nuevo a mi n8 en que
me pide miren acá me pide acá si voy a colocar esto y voy a crear otra credencial que me pide
miren me pide la id y me pide así que el clíendos secret ya la client id ya lo tengo y hasta acá
estos lo copian en un en un blog de notas muy aparte y lo pegan en acá ya aquí lo vea como
es para mostrarles nomás solo me pido hacer esto ahora lo que es mi contraseña digamos que no se
acuerdan en cosas ya aquí hemos creado anterior clases de acuerdo esto puedo copiarlo pero fíjense
ya no se puede copiar ni éste tampoco es que hago puedo añadir un nuevo secu no eva clave secreta
aquí les va para ustedes añadir hagan eso si es que se han olvidado y les va a añadir el
sistema ahora tiene una cantidad definida por su caso esto lo voy a borrar yo porque ya no lo
utilizo lo puedo borrar y navitar puedo colocarlo y lo inhabilito y lo voy a borrar porque me ocupa
espacio lo borro y miren si me va a dejar otro crearme porque máximo tiene una cantidad específica
ya y fíjense acá la configuración puede tener cinco y algunas horas en aplicarse por
ese caso así que tengan cuidado por eso siempre traten de guardar porque si no se va a tener que
hacer lo mismo que estoy haciendo ahorita y va a ser más complicado las cuestionantes y eso
y esto este es clave secreta cuando añada añadir secreto lo copian y lo pegan de nuevo a su
blog de notas ya una vez que lo copian de 100 ustedes pueden venir acá en su y pueden copiarlo
acá en este caso en el mío es este es la y vi la yendo y lo voy a pegar acá y obviamente la
clave secreta que ya tenía yo lo voy a pegar acá listo ya y pueden en este caso loguearse se
loguean y tienen que trabajar con él con el ojo en este caso estoy trabajando con este cuenta de
gmail tiene que ser con la misma cuenta con la cual tienen que lograrse listo
ya ahora sí van a continuar y van a colocar accesos a todo y todo a continuar esto y lo
van a dar accesos a otro y ya está conexión y su su ya éxitos y esta parte ustedes me tienen
que sacarte mi nscr y listo esto les va a funcionar ojo siempre cuando la anterior clase ya han
trabajado conmigo porque el vídeo yo lo sé no voy a subir más rato para para cualquier tipo de si
se han olvidado o era no han podido tomar datos si o si van a tener que hacer con esto ya
listo una vez que ya lo tengan ahí los que me han salido anterior clase van a hacer lo siguiente
lo cierran y ahora sí ya pueden probar ya vamos a probar algunos aspectos como ya no
la habilitadora vamos a enviarnos un correo ya se enviamos un correo vamos a ejecutarlo a ver
vamos a ejecutarlo
y fíjense ya me ha enviado y tendría que estar en esta cuenta de gravity si vengo acá
miren ya está ven voy a hacer esto pedidos coca cola señor mil mil ton tanto ser enviado
miren ya me está diciendo esto
ahí me dice así que normal trabajamos ya ahora vamos a hacer algo más interesante
estas cositas que están viendo acá podemos automatizarlo de manera un poquito más interesante
pero digamos que yo quiero que cuando un cliente entre a mí en para mi software o a mi a mi página
quiero que automáticamente mi software o mi n8n le responda sin que yo esté entrando qué hago
si se dan cuenta acá tengo que estar colocando sí o sí mi correo pero qué puedo hacer fácil miren
este email voy a borrar esto y voy a dejar el email acá
ya está qué está haciendo eso automáticamente cualquier entrada que tenga acá con el con el
con cualquier usuario que vaya usando con su propio cuenta de gmail le voy a reenviar
automáticamente con el sistema de n8n ya entonces aquí a la pos ya todos los servicios de la
zona tanto tanto ya ella voy a tener ahora aquí puedo colocar esta parte si está vamos a abrir
nos ahora una una ventana de incógnito voy a abrir con esto pero no perjudicaré venimos acá
voy a venir acá no hay ventana de incógnito voy a entrar en chachipiti
en chachipiti le voy a decir lo siguiente voy a copiarme todo esto antes
voy a copiarme todo y le voy a dar algún tipo de
prompt para que me lo haga y nos veía acá y voy a hacer lo siguiente
en base a este modelo
créame una
un html para respuesta en correo electrónico
gmail ya voy a colocar añade dale a ver si dale
dale voy a hacer antes esto y por lo que se puede estar acá
vamos a hacer que el de color es dale algo de color
y formato
formato vamos a colocarle tipo respuesta
listo le decimos eso y aquí me dice miren me va a generar esto todo esto
ya
ahora esto yo lo puedo copiar lo copio
y lo voy a pegar acá de mi
proyecto acá en vez de todo esto yo lo voy a borrar y lo voy a pegar y además le voy a decir
que le envíen html ahora en html ya lo voy a ejecutar ya pero en este caso yo quiero
mandarle si me encanta esto voy a mantener para hacer la prueba antes de hacerlo de más es que
voy a volver a copiar mi cuentita acá y luego va a ser automáticamente con ustedes pero
mientras tanto yo quiero hacer esto con mi cuenta primero para empezar con los demás
se lo voy a volver a borrar y lo voy a mantener listo ya ahora si ejecutamos
y ya está ya me enviado ahora voy a irme a mi cuenta
si vámonos acá voy a venir acá miren acá hago clic y miren qué bonito me sale
hola señor milton informar que se le enviado y haber estado del pedido gracias por confiar
en nosotros si tienen solución estará mostrando y listo ven esta parte si está chicos saca en
un screen y lo añaden en su documento word
ya listo
captura no sé qué captura es pero es captura
2 captura 3 es esto captura 4
ahora si
ya hasta ahí si será que lo vayan ejecutando vayan sacando se los voy a dar un poquito de tiempo
por qué ahora los voy a enviar a cada uno de ustedes
vayan dando los tilos pregunten lo chatcito que quieren que es específico
por si acaso por si acaso por si acaso por si acaso ya aquí le pueden añadir incluso imágenes
ya no pueden añadir por ejemplo
voy a añadir una
os añadir dentro de acá
bueno si los estorba esto no pueden leerlo pueden clicar acá ahora si pueden hacerlo de manera
mucho más aplicativa ya por ejemplo en mi food art quiero yo
no sé lo que voy a colocar acá digamos ahora sí existos lo voy a colocar
ya voy a colocar así y más y en vez de
ser ese igual 12 puntos ahora voy a buscarme de acá una imagen voy a irme a otro navegador
pero no generarme problemas voy a buscar una imagen a ver imagen de coca cola
listo voy a venir acá voy a hacer esto clic derecho y voy a copiarme copiar dirección
de la imagen y se me hace un clic vengo acá y voy a pegarlo acá y esto lo voy a hacer
obviamente listo ya está lo actualizan y lo volvamos a ejecutar
listo ahora voy a irme de nuevo a mi gmail ya esta parte
vamos a ver cómo funciona
listo ahora si esto voy a minimizar un poco para que puedan ver
y ahí está vengo acá
y en día dice coca cola
pueden obviamente reducirlo esto pueden venir acá y pueden colocar donde estaba mi aquí
wait hate o sea la altura del ancho puede modificar ahí
ya y nada más eso sería todo ahora sí esa parte voy a nacer a chicos porque quiero que ustedes
hagan de manera diferente o sea que tengan sus propios desde la chatcito les va a decir que
qué color quieren que imaginen que hicieran qué características no lo voy ojo cuando hagan esto
no lo haga muy pesado que les dé chat porque hay veces les va a votar errores porque algunos
parámetros no entienden y en 8 n dentro de acá netamente maneja html si les quiere meter
cosas no va a manejar los ayer errores y si hacen un flujo extremo de datos igual es
batalla rojo yo no los recomiendo que hagan muchas cosas solamente para una cosa formal las
cosas formales realmente no lleva mucha bueno aquí le decimos muchas muchas adornitos en
ese aspecto eso hasta ahí les espero chicos y ahora vamos a proceder a enviarles a cada
hombre así los dos minutitos ya mientras tanto de mancacheta chico cosa se va a pagar la con la
compu que primero otra y más que se mueren y se no también a los de tiempitos de mientras
vayan enviando mi vayan que se llama tu hondo en el bordo
esos interesantes y de sus empresas que estas están pensándose ya esa partecita
y
parece que se paga que se se paga ya
y ahora espero chicos hasta 40 ya vamos a automatizarlo con ustedes
y ya
ya estoy entonces
ahora sí una vez que tienen todo eso que pasa valería
en una consulta por favor en la página que va a subir todo esta la información de la clase
en la que ha estado subiendo anteriormente es que todo porque yo soy un poquito lenta o sea
intento seguir el ritmo pero igual siempre veo las grabaciones para completar lo que me faltó
porque me retrasé un poco durante las clases claro no los voy a seguir enviando así entre entre
entre comillas del grupo para que no nos digan no les digan nada la embajada ya porque según el
reglamento de este no te prohibiré un reglamento dice que estoy prohibido de grabar por cuestiones pero
sé que algunas veces es necesario grabar porque siempre no tienen dudas así que yo voy a mantener
siempre cuando no me venda en chicas y ahora sí entonces en base yo también lo voy a subir
por si caso otros vídeos y además más cómo les explico más detallado con más calma y más
de forma directa en el youtube así que lo vectoré ayer subí creo que la segunda vídeo hoy voy a
subir unos dos vídeos más hasta donde no les he pasado el vídeo y van a tener todo completo
junto con esto ya ahora sí hable en esta cosa el email a vos lo en esto ahora si les mandaré a ustedes
vos lo nesto y hale en esto ya ahora sí ahora aquí chicos hay cuidado que tengan problemas porque
este procesamiento de datos esto lo especaría un cachito antes de que continúen miran acá
la secuencia que tiene que tener un envío de datos una captura de datos
es el que hace la captura y es el que va a enviar pero es el que va a insertar o sea que vas a
excepcionar los que las capturas de datos ahora en vez de este pueden utilizar su su propia página web
o sea si ustedes se compran un dominio barato tiene su página web crean su formulario
ya no es necesario esto lo pueden eliminar pueden trabajar ahora con web hooks los web hooks
me va a ayudar a qué a capturar los datos que esté ingresando desde su propio sistema web
ya y es más fácil porque porque ingresan porque en mi sistema web puedo yo tener cosas
bastante interesantes a un interfaz bonita colores atrayentes la marca que yo estoy generando y
todo eso yo lo puedo adjuntar ya eso es lo bueno pero ahorita luego vamos a hacer eso vamos a
llegar a ese punto no hay problema ahorita esas opciones hay ahora este señor que estamos
viendo acá el formulario de contacto envía los datos al procesamiento de datos y el procesamiento
de datos lo envía decenas y me ya y el gmail obviamente me va a enviar a mí pero fíjense acá
si hago doble clic acá
ya fíjense lo que voy a hacer a esto parte perdón voy a hacer clic acá en semestras en el gmail
si si esto cliqueo miren cliqueo aquí también hay otro gmail
y si en vez de esto lo copio ese va a funcionar igual va a funcionar igual pero que es lo malo
que yo no estoy analizando el proceso de datos directamente estoy obteniendo directamente del
formulario a mi gmail eso no es conveniente porque uno voy a romper procesos dos voy a
generar bucles váscilos y tres voy a generar en este caso autenticaciones que pueden generar
algún baneo de datos puede haber una caída del sistema y demás así que esa parte yo no les
recomiendo he visto muchos proyectos que han hecho mis alumnos que todos van puesto ahí y luego están
reclamando porque a lo largo ya no funciona para el día de su defensa y es difícil a veces decirles
y porque se hace los he dicho en clases digamos eso tienen que tomar en cuenta ya voy a cerrar
esta parte los cerramos ahora voy a irme a producción ya voy a irme a cantas voy a hacer
lo siguiente esto lo voy a llevar a producción lo mismo chicos esto quiero que siempre se acuerdan
vamos a hacer clic acá ahora voy a irme a mí acá a mi gmail para ayudarme esta parte lo voy a
borrar que estaba no mis radios listo bueno más abajo control b ojo estoy en modo producción ahora
voy a copiar esto y luego ya pegar acá listo ahí esta parte de tema voy a copiar y los enviar
pero antes de hacer eso yo lo voy a cerrar un poco y le voy a colocar pública van a colocar el publish
y listo y go y listo y hasta ahora si les voy a pasar el url
y en este caso me va a llegar un montón de datos a mí aquí a mí a mi cuenta principal me va a
llegar de ustedes ya no me llenen el correo nada más porque voy a hacerlo un cachito ya nada más
listo ya lo si empezaremos eso ya pasa el link al mit
el listo voy a ver de quién está llegando sus mensajes y lo mismo pueden ser inversamente
este ya los he enviado chicos a ver yo voy a minimizar esto un cachón
y listo
y a vayan me llenan pidiendo sus pedidos
para que yo voy a admitir
y
y me llenando y voy haciendo eso voy a seguir actualizando para ver si me ha llegado alguno de
ustedes
a veces a ver errores pero hay que esperar un cacho porque esta parte si te da como art
van a enviar y una bucle y feo
y listo voy a ejecutar esta parte para que tengamos ejecutaremos el workflow
ahora voy a enviar yo uno mientras tanto
vayan vayan haciendo esto
listo vamos a colocar
voy a ver si está bien capaz no está bien algo lo hemos hallado y voy a ver si
en este caso
y
a Coca Cola voy a pedir pépstas y que listo ya fíjense si bajo esto miren ha llegado
ven se tienen que cumplir esas cositas verdes que ven el todo de flujo ahora si voy a irme acá
creo que me enviado mi mucho correo no
si voy a irme a mi mucho correo perdón
no está mi mucho correo
voy a irme a mi mucho correo ya hay debe estar llegando todo si eso sé
listo
ya ya me he llegado
yo sabe de llegar a ustedes igual
verifican a ver en sus correos
ya por ejemplo acá me he llegado miren
listo ahí está
nada más ya eso verifiquen ustedes en sus propios correos que se los está enviando
nada más
listo a ver ejecución es constant y si no hay 46 en vía de 1 dice no con el sabido 8 de 45
han enviado varios ven varios son enviadorita les ha verificado ahorita tengo registrados
1 2 3 4 5 por 6 por 7 8 9 10 10 anembiadorita ya pueden ver así tienen que trabajar en manera
cuando trabajen en producción nada más yo listo chico
bueno
esta es la atención que este muestra depende de la capacidad de
este almacenado de este este servicio exa más que toda la capacidad de su computadora
claro para hablar del tema de producción ya se determinaría digamos no
si es si es el 1 de perro se detecta o algo así para que se entiende a lo que se necesita
no exacto es que hay igual mejoras que se puede adquirir con el n8n que está barata
pongan el extra 0 5 dólares para mejorar la latencia porque esto me ayuda a ese tipo de
sistemas pero también en el 8n ve la fase de en donde pueden implementar este tipo de prospectos o
aspectos porque si tenemos un negocio o una empresa dedicada no siempre va a llegar al mismo
tiempo correos no puede generalmente en el 8 n lo mantiene la latencia un a un segundo
si en ese segundo choca más de cinco seis siete datos ahí sí puede haber sobre
sobre posición de datos así que se que tener muy en cuenta cuando se trabaja en local ya
pero si se puede mejorar eso vamos a avanzar las siguientes clases para ver en otros prospectos
porque ahorita en gmail no siempre va a pasar eso es muy raro pero cuando ya tengamos otro
tipo de software donde tenemos que adjuntar verificar los datos ahí si es bien complicadito ahí si hay
que tener muy en cuenta las latencias ya por ejemplo en el orden no ve por ejemplo si ustedes van a
tomar un examen a sus alunos y sus alumnos tienen que enviar si o si hasta tal tal hora no ve
pero saben que sus alumnos a último ahora mandan todo y saben que puede ocurrir eso y
como por ejemplo vamos a tratar de corregir esto porque esto no tiene un backup y eso hay que
tomar también en cuenta pues vamos a avanzar algunos puntos más adelante en los cursos
mucho más específicas ya no no es el único texto de cierto entonces aparte de eso hay otro
otra cosa que cambia cuando se con los envía bueno cuando se prepara para producción es decir
si esa parte se utiliza autenticación pero esa parte igual vamos a ver las
siguientes pero normal igual tendría que dar carros pero aparte de esto es
lo más conveniente de ver si quieren hacer un proceso un poquito más específicos es que en vez
de utilizar esto pueden mantener con un html así con un custom y al hacer esto puedo añadir
algunos atributos como ejemplo html y hay mejorar algunas características del código por ejemplo
si yo quiero que funcione de manera correcta no me envíe cosas extremas pueden colocar ahí y
darle formato ya incluso aquí se le puede añadir algo de criptografía para evitar todos
sus aspectos y que mejore la latencia podrían añadir script para sanitizar alguna central
si y no de mucho depende el tipo de entrar porque aquí abajo se da cuenta dice no aceptamos script
ni estilos o algún tipo de inputs eso no te acepto pero sí con código código
se ha dicho algo si exactamente listo yo eso que la prueba vayan viendo cómo sale con esto
o sea siempre hagan pruebas locales y eso cuando llegan en producción y en cuando
se quieran comprar algún tipo de cuenta pues ya van a saber qué hacer porque esto es como
les digo la curiosidad siempre es bueno y obviamente fregándolas aprenden así que vayan viendo metiendo
datos todos aspectos listo bueno hasta ahí vamos a llegar chicos ojo solamente tengo las pregómas
las personas que me han sus asistencias si nos vayan completando me diría tengo ahorita cuantas
14 tengo cuantas una ahorita 19 ya menos 2 que soy yo a menos 3 está bien falta un poquito
después vamos comprétenlo ya voy a sacar las estencias chicos de mi cachito no se va a salir
todavía voy a sacar asistencias aparte para ver para enviar como captura a su sistema y esto
y avanzando lo igual y lo demás ya de un cachito
ya a ver algo más
voy a colocar esto
esta parte voy a sacar algunas cosas
a menos que estoy sacando escribiendo con la cola a ver que no le digan
y listo y voy a sacar las asistencias dejen de compartir
voy a guardar esto espero que esté grabando